boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation I'm your host Alan Saki and
we are still on site in San Jose at the
American anthropological association's
annual meeting we are now sitting down
with Dr Daniel Ginsburg hello hey how
you doing thanks for coming on to the
show yeah sure greatly appreciate it
Daniel's awesome he's got a great
background he's manager of Education
research and professional development at
AAA
he's also an anthropologist in Residence
at American University in Washington DC
got his PhD in linguistics from
Georgetown So Daniel I'd love to learn
more about all of this from you let's
start with how you even fell in love
with anthropology in the first place
yeah that's uh it took me a while I
first thought of myself as an
anthropologist in my fourth year of my
grad program
my background was and I had I had
previous careers as a school teacher and
I had decided I wanted to study
Linguistics so I started off studying
Applied Linguistics and that took me
into sociolinguistics and I was working
in classrooms trying to figure out how
students and teachers talk to one
another and learn more about that so
eventually the way that took me was sort
of into anthropology because I realized
that if I was going to understand what
was going on I needed to understand the
whole
social setting of it and it so happened
that my advisor was actually a bona fide
Anthropologist and so he brought me
along
what were you learning about when you
were learning about how teachers and
students communicate so my research in
grad school was on mathematics education
I was really interested in how students
learn to talk about math and how they
think about themselves as being
successful math Learners or not because
so many people have a hard time
imagining themselves in that way and it
was interesting to see the different
ways that that came out through the ways
that they talked in class and then the
ways that they talked about it when I
would interview them later
and how how what was the difference
there so there's a couple of different
uh potential barriers that make it hard
for people to see themselves in it so
the first one is if you think about
for a lot of people math is a study of
like X and Y and it's hard to know if
you don't know what X and Y actually are
um you don't really relate to it and you
don't see much purpose in it the second
one is that there's this idea that math
is the subject where there's always
exactly one right answer which doesn't
have to be that way there are other ways
of teaching math but in a lot of cases
that's what it is for a lot of students
that's what they like about it but for a
lot of other students they'll say look
if there's one right answer if the
teacher knows the right answer what are
you asking me for
um and if I can't get it then I just
feel bad about myself
and then the third level is there's this
idea of people will say I'm not a math
person right like if you're educated
adults say I'm not a math person in the
same way you would never hear them say
like oh a book well I'm not a reading
person right
um but the people say oh I can't figure
out the the tip on our on our restaurant
bill you figure it out
um and so I was really curious about
what's behind that and if there's an
idea that some people are meth people
and some people are not and if you're
not there's no way to become one then
once you get that idea in your head it's
very difficult to
figure out how to get there from here or
even to care about it much those are
really interesting points of analysis I
I think the one right answer one's
really interesting the if you already
have the answer why asking me these are
all very interesting and also the not
math person one there's there's this
very strange
it's something that I've continuously
explain to people when they say that I
don't really like math I'm non-math
person which is that you do math all the
time you just don't know that it's math
right like when you're crossing a
sidewalk you have to calculate well how
long how many seconds I have left until
the crosswalks thought and that like
you're actually doing calculation can I
walk fast enough to make it on time yeah
Etc when you're driving the same thing
what time do I need to leave for the
airport what time do you need to leave
for the airport all this different type
of stuff yeah so okay so then after that
how did you do the yeah what was the
thesis in linguistics and how did you
get into you know Georgetown to do that
um so I had been a
a public school teacher like I said in
my last career I was teaching English as
a second language to students in a
public high school outside of Boston
um so I worked there and I had studied
um
comparative literature and math in my
undergrad
so it came up at a certain time that our
students who were learning English it
was a teenage immigrants and refugees
um
there was sort of this idea that they
didn't need particular help to learn
math that they might need in English or
science or US history
but in a lot of cases that wasn't really
true and so I realized that I could get
my teaching license also in math and
learn how to work with them and be able
to work with them you know within what
the school would allow for us to be able
to offer them linguistically appropriate
mathematics instruction so I did that
for two years and it was really a
struggle because
the way that sort of best practices and
doing that kind of work as you say for
each lesson that I have you know
students are going to learn this piece
of math and they're going to learn that
piece of English
and it has to go together because it's
one lesson and I really struggled to
figure out what would be an appropriate
sort of language objective
and I remember I asked you know we had
an instructional coach and I asked her
about it and she said um
well if you're if you're doing let's say
for example you're teaching students how
to graph linear equations in the plane
then you could say students will learn
the vocabulary of graphing linear
equations in the plane
which it felt to me like a cup out right
it's like there's more to it than
vocabulary yeah um but there wasn't
really good science on what that was or
if there was it wasn't accessible to me
as a high school teacher you know the
education research that we were exposed
to would be like somebody did a study
with 50 000 kids and they tried a thing
and it made a difference in their test
scores and I really wanted something
that I could recognize on the scale of
I'm working with this group of 20 kids
every single day
rather than a huge group that I saw one
time so
that's how I ended up also I mean
interested in anthropology and
ethnography because it really it reads
on that level of that a practitioner can
recognize from their work experience
um but also until I got into the
classroom discourse because I wanted to
try and figure out like what what is the
language of math I had a job in between
where I worked in language testing and
it was one of the standards that we
worked on was we wanted to assess
students knowledge of the language of
math
and they didn't really have a good sort
of concept of what that is precisely and
so that was what took me into asking the
questions that I asked in grad school
and so then a lot of them is in my right
that the Linguistics analysis for you
was in relation to how students learned
math it was it was mostly what I was
working with was video recordings that I
made of math classes in session there
are two classrooms where I was working
one was a middle school class for
English Learners kind of like what I had
been doing in my in my previous career
but with younger kids and the other was
a
a college calculus section
and so I would go in every
once a week and video the entire class
session and then I would take it home
and transcribe it and do different kinds
of analysis and while I was there I
would also take field notes because I
thought it was a really good way to keep
myself keyed in and remember the kind of
things that I was noticing and that I
might want to follow up on later yeah
whoa so so a lot of then the
what are some of the I guess the
solutions then to helping with the way
that we speak about math
that's a great question and I think it's
important to think about how research
feeds into practical Solutions
within the bounds of my grad program I
didn't really have space to do as much
as I could have but what I became aware
of a lot was that there were interesting
points of intersection between what I
was doing and what people were doing in
math education there's a lot of really
sort of Cutting Edge work on trying to
take down some of these same barriers to
students seeing themselves as successful
Learners so the one right answer thing
there's a there's a a lot of work around
that from people in in mathematics
education in the learning Sciences so to
give an example like there are ways of
asking the same question in a way that
has multiple right answers
and then you can have a conversation
about it
so the example that I like to to use is
I could ask you if I have a rectangle
that's four units by six units what's
the area and then I'm asking you can you
multiply four by six and tell me what
you get or I can say I have a rectangle
that's 24 square units what are the
dimensions
oh interesting and so then if I have one
student says four by six and one says
six by four then we can say well is that
or is it not the same thing if one
student says four by six and one says
three by eight then we can say could
they both be right and then once we've
decided that they could both be right we
could say well how many right answers
are there how will you know when you've
got them all
if you have one that's 48 by one half
does that count and so then you can
really get into a lot of that
understanding and you can sort of get
around the one right answer thing that
some people find to be a barrier
um that was a really good example
I like that one thanks yeah
whoa yeah because in math we're never we
were never taught what you just taught I
think maybe we were taught a four by six
or six by four but I don't think we were
taught that it was all
that the purpose in so many ways was
that in in the way that you're
describing the importance of it being
that there is more than one right answer
right yeah and it's it really gets you
thinking more deeply as a teacher right
about am I trying to get my kids to know
how to find the right answer or am I
trying to get them to understand
something about geometry on a deeper
level than just like can I solve can I
answer the question quickly yeah
um in a lot of sort of more traditional
ways of teaching math there's so much
emphasis that's put on speed
you know I remember as a kid having
these sheets with like 100
multiplication facts and I had to see
how many I could fill out yeah and some
kids are good at that and for ones who
are not it just makes them feel bad
about themselves and when you're
actually doing math like as a
professional mathematician
it's like it's not related to that at
all that's not the kind of thing they
work on and so
one thing that's really interesting is
to think about how you can make school
math be more of an exploration in the
way that professional you know research
pure math might be
at an appropriate level
wow
that's a really cool point so what do
you have another cool one that that we
could get better at with Linguistics and
learning like within math or other
subjects one thing that I think about is
there's a there's a a book that I was
reading by a
one of these math education people
um
his name's uh
Christopher Danielson and he wrote a
like a shapes book for kids where
traditionally they're like here's a
triangle and you ask your kid like oh
what is it it's a triangle okay and so
by the same token like that's not an
interesting thing and so his book um
he's done a couple but the first one was
which one doesn't belong and so it's
like a two by two and you have four
different shapes and the question was
which one of these shapes doesn't belong
with the other three
but the trick is
the way that he's designed it is it
could be any of them
oh interesting there's whichever three
you pick they have something in common
that the other one doesn't have yeah
so they all look kind of similar right
it's like shaped so it can be like a
triangle and three rectangles but
two of the rectangles and the triangle
are shaded in and the other rectangle is
not you know it's this kind of thing and
so I can say so they have symbol three
of them have a similarity that one
doesn't have right right but whichever
three you pick they have some similarity
yeah and so then I guess it is
linguistic because then what happens is
the point of it is not the answer the
point is the conversation that you have
yeah and the right answer is that the
right answer is anything where your
reasoning is true yeah
and so I'm not interested in did you
which one did you pick I'm interested in
how did you explain why you picked it
and that's why it tells me whether you
pick the right one or not yeah this is a
proof yeah it's basically a proof but
it's a proof at a level that like
six-year-olds can do it yeah yeah
correct that's so interesting I like
that example a lot too
wow what a cool what a cool way to apply
uh Linguistics to uh opening up the
conversation around around math and
getting more people involved and and
feeling like they have a a role to play
in in math okay now
so now what is it like as you manage
education research professional
development at AAA what does that mean
what does it look like
yeah that's I mean it's a lot it's it's
a it's a very long job title
um
the reason that it's so long is that we
were talking about me working on
research and me working on education and
be working on professional development
we wanted to pick two out of three to
make it a reasonable length
um But whichever one we left out just
like which one doesn't belong it's like
whichever one we left out
it didn't quite hold together and so we
decided we needed to include the whole
thing so the way it breaks down is the
research is basically research on the
profession of anthropology
so for the association it's important
for us to know things like
how many people are studying
anthropology in U.S colleges and
universities and what is that number
do we know
I should shouldn't I
um it's like a couple tens of thousands
it's something that so at the
undergraduate level it's in that range
and then I want to say
um
maybe 1500 master's degrees and 500 phds
are granted a year something in that
ballpark okay um and maybe maybe eight
to ten thousand bachelor's degrees yeah
um okay okay but so we have like
resources so we produce resources to to
share that kind of information with
people we also do like snapshots of this
year of of all the degrees that were
granted what part of the country were
they granted in how did the people who
earned them
um break down according to gender and
racial classifications because those are
things that we can monitor to see how
inclusive the discipline is and start
you know not because we want to ask
everybody what race you are because
that's not really interesting or
appropriate but because we want to have
ways of starting conversations about
being more inclusive as a discipline
totally
um
uh but we also said we have research
that we do on our own Association
members
um just to know like what kind of jobs
they're doing and how they've arrived at
where they're at and what they want to
get out of the association and how they
feel engaged with it
um
we have a a project that I'm really
excited about because you know one
question that comes up a lot is
what do you do with a bachelor's degree
in anthropology
um good question yeah and I've heard
people say you know you can do whatever
you want with it which is true but it's
not helpful so we want to try and find
ways of giving more concrete specifics
and if there's anything that
anthropology is good for it's telling
stories
so uh this year we're going to have a
group of five really six undergraduate
research fellows it's five but one is a
team of two
um who are going to be doing research on
this topic at their own home
institutions working together
collaboratively online so they can sort
of share the experience and support one
another as they go through it but the
goal is for them because they're really
living it but also that they can really
dig into this question that's important
to so many people about how do
anthropology Majors plan for what comes
next after they graduate yeah you know
on the one level I can look at census
data and say you know uh there's so many
thousands of people in the U.S census
who report when they do the American
Community survey they say do you have a
four-year degree if so in what so they
ask a certain number of people who have
degrees in anthropology and then they
say what sector of of the economy is
your job in and what are your job
responsibilities and and we can say like
do some statistics and say okay
anthropologists are way more likely to
do a certain kinds of jobs that have to
do with explaining culture to other
people
so anthropology majors are more likely
than others to be Museum creators social
scientists librarians
and
that's good on a certain level that we
have those numbers but we'll really also
want to be able to tell the story and we
want to bring the anthropology to that
question
um and be able to talk about you know
what was this process like for these
students as they went through it how did
they talk about it amongst themselves
how do they imagine their future selves
doing anthropology somewhere
and it's it's like the math students
right how do they how do they see
themselves getting from here to there
um
so social scientists Librarians Museum
creators Museum curators yeah nice
there's this idea that if you're gonna
study anthropology you're gonna end up
as a college professor because it's the
only place to do it but what we found
looking at the statistical analysis of
the Census Data is that anthropology
majors are no more I mean they do
do that some amount of the time but
they're no more likely to do it than any
other liberal arts major oh so it's not
like anthropology is uniquely poorly
supported for like other kinds of work
it just takes more effort to figure out
for any individual person exactly what
that is
because it's so
adaptable and like so broadly useful
um so we want to find ways of telling
more success stories that's what I was
just about to say it'd be cool to to get
more anthropologists excited about
telling stories that are relatable for
the general public about how Society has
evolved or what certain what certainly
what's currently going on in certain
Geographic locations around the planet
yeah certain demographics around the
planet so I love storytelling we love
storytelling so if that could be
something that you said so there's
there's these groups now that are six
six of these individuals that are going
at their local institutions to do
research on where anthropology Majors go
for work
if we could funnel into into
storytelling it'd be great now what what
else is
um with managing educational research
and professional development yeah what
else yeah yeah so that's the research
piece okay and the research piece like I
said it's important for us to know these
things because people will call us up
and say you know in my department we
have had this and that change in the
number of Majors we have year over year
does that mirror trends that are
happening in the discipline more broadly
and we can talk about that but it's also
important for us to be able to support
professional development offerings that
the association provides to its members
and also for us to be able to support
public education Outreach initiatives
for broader public and so that's the the
professional development piece and the
education piece which I also work on and
then what does that look like for AAA to
do Outreach to the public
um it takes a lot of different forms
probably the the
Keystone example that we've had the best
example of successes that we've had
doing that is a traveling Museum exhibit
that we had that was going around the
country for the 10 years it's about to
wrap up called race are we so different
interesting and so this was traveling
Museum exhibits yeah there was one there
was so much demand for it that they made
a copy of it and then there was still so
much this van for that they made a third
copy of it that's smaller that can fit
into smaller spaces and it draws from
all different ways of doing anthropology
to talk about first of all what is the
science of human biological variation
and then the second thing is how how is
that used to classify people according
to racial categories and then the third
thing is what what
ramifications does that have for the
lived experience of people you know as
they go through their lives and dealing
with race in different ways or not
um and so the museum exhibit built in
all of these things
it's just wrapping up a 10-year run
going all over the country and then we
also produced a number of you know there
was a book 10-year run yeah we expected
it to be less than they keep people kept
asking for it um there was a book there
was a before we get in the book what was
the the in what were some of the
interesting takeaways from like the
variations and what that means about
race for race are we so different
um so there are some really cool things
that that came out as part of the
materials that we used so for example
what we did was we had a group of people
who had um t-shirts printed up where it
would say at various points over the
last 100 years or so how would they have
been classified racially on the U.S
census because there's this sort of
naive idea that race is this inherent
thing of of humans that it's like you
know we just anthropologists know
there's no scientific biological basis
for it
um there's not you know if you had a if
you had a
sort of hypothetical Martian come and
look at who people are just as animals
there's not like a different species
that are white folks and black folks
that's not scientific that's that's
social and it's it's racist thinking
that then makes these categories
um but then you can go back and look at
the interesting so it goes under the
umbrella of humans and not a specific
genetic variation right right like
there's more genetic variation within a
race than there is from One race to
another
you know and so what it looks like on
the on the genetic level is that it's
one species and it's very clear science
um but the other thing too with it being
something that that comes out of human
society is that that is also a moving
Target
and so the way that people think about
racial classification over time changes
yeah and so we found a really cool way
to illustrate that where we would have
people wear a t-shirt that would say you
know if I were alive in 1910 I would
have been called this yeah if I were
alive in 1950 I would have been called
that and then when I filled out the 2010
census I put this other thing yeah and
you can see that it's not the same thing
from here what would be the example of
what how someone is so
um before the 1970s we didn't really
have an idea of Hispanic or Latino or
latinx as people say now
um there was a census category this
wasn't in the race category it was um
and still the census asks about race and
ethnicity separately and so this is the
ethnicity question is are you Hispanic
Latino or not
um but this wasn't even a thing that
they would ask about up until the 1970s
there were census designations for
Spanish surname
um but there really wasn't a sense that
um people who were descended from Latin
American uh
countries or Latin American immigrants
to the U.S would necessarily form a
cohesive social group and so there was
really a social project in the 1970s to
build that identity for U.S political
purposes and then it's interesting too
that even now you can see when migrants
arrive in the U.S from Latin America
they kind of have to learn to be latinx
because it's like before I was just
Nicaraguan
and in Nicaragua they might have other
different ways of thinking about race
that don't
map neatly onto what we do you're
filling out a different census survey
right in Nicaragua than you are in the
U.S right and and what I think of myself
as being the same category as a
Guatemalan or a Salvadoran or a Mexican
or an Argentine right just because we
all speak Spanish yeah but in the U.S
the politics of it is different and so
the classification is different and it's
something that's really come up pretty
recently that is so interesting
whoa
um yeah how you can evolve over time as
so but we we were really not even taking
census surveys really of populations
prior to 1900 were we I don't know how I
mean so the it's in the Constitution
that we do the a census every 10 years
okay um so that we can figure out um
who's living here or how what where the
congressional districts are going to be
how many representatives does each state
get in Congress is proportionate to the
population so it's in the Constitution
we have to count everyone
um every 10 years so that goes back to
the 1790s why California has more votes
than South Dakota right yeah
um but uh
the development of social science along
with that over the last you know
hundreds of years and and so the the U.S
census now does a lot more of that kind
of work
um yeah interesting and then the the
other thing you said was um there's more
genetic variation within a race than
from a race to another race yeah
interesting so there's more genetic
variation between two French people than
there is between a French and like a
South African person
um well it's hard to look at it on the
level of individuals okay right like how
many genes do I have in common with you
personally is and this is I'm getting
way out of my area yeah yeah it's better
this is an exhibit yeah this is an
exhibit I just was finding the exhibits
so interesting and we have genetic
anthropologists here that I could hook
you up with that would be interesting
but my understanding of it is if you
look at the population as a whole right
if if there were if races were a real
scientific fact then you would say if I
look at your DNA that there would be
like different Trends where like all of
these people's DNA is similar to each
other and different from them
right and if you look at groups of
people
it's it's not the case that's not how it
is
um it's it's that
um we have these racial groups that
we've decided on because of culture and
history but if you look at the DNA of
people within that group they don't hang
together as a unit in that way they just
look like human DNA
and so then this is part of the
education piece and then is there
another exhibit that's going up or what
yeah how does that yeah we're currently
working on a successor so we're revising
some of the race material so I said it's
it's been in the
um
in the field for 10 years that means
that it was first going out around the
time that Barack Obama was elected
president
and so if we're thinking about you know
race and culture in the United States
there has been so much in the last 10
years so we've been working on updating
those materials to reflect a lot of
what's happened since then from Obama to
Black lives matter to a lot of other
things that have come out
um
and at the same time as that because the
museum exhibit is winding down we're
also starting to ramp up another thing
which is called World on the Move 100
000 years of human migration yeah that
sounds cool yeah so we have done we're
we're still working on finding the
resources to put together the museum
exhibit for that but we've done uh some
writing in our own so in anthropology
news as I remember newsletter and we've
had a series of articles about migration
under that
heading we have a collaboration that
we've done over a number of years with
the Smithsonian Center for Folklife and
cultural heritage where they put on a
the Folklife Festival on the National
Mall every year and we've had uh
presence there working on it's all
always ties in with migration in some
way because they bring in cultural
heritage performers from around the
world and so then it's been a real great
opportunity for us to have conversations
about that and in collaboration with
such a good partner what does a hundred
thousand years of migration look like
um what are you guys going to be
showcasing there's there's a lot of
different angles on it and so we're
still working through a lot of the
details but there is sort of the Long
View story that you can tell of how the
the human species began in in East
Africa and now populates you know the
entire world
how did that happen and and what is the
evidence that we use to tell that story
um
you know and you can tell the story in
terms of DNA you can tell it in terms of
Bones you can tell it in terms of uh
cultural practices and food you can tell
it in terms of language you can you can
find artifacts that that show how
culture was shared between people from
here to here to here and so it brings
together all different ways of doing
anthropology to tell that story in the
long term but then there are also more
micro stories that you can tell about
specific instances of you know in this
place
um
who lived here
and then who came here why did they come
where did they come from and what
happened to the people who are already
there yeah
um and there were there were that story
has happened in a lot of ways in a lot
of places over the last hundred thousand
years and we're still working out
exactly what that's going to look like
when we
um build it out
um but that's that's the kind of stories
that we're looking to tell
oh man there's yeah there's so many
variables to calculate for this story of
the hundred thousand years of migration
and and I like I like all the angles
that you want to take on it that's
the way to do it now
um I want to ask you about what's going
on with the Anthropologist in residency
at American University in Washington DC
because I the air the Anthropologist in
Residence is so interesting so like what
is that like this is a brand new thing
that I've just been been doing recently
it's it's
um
my goal was never to be a college
professor even though I got my PhD I was
just interested in doing this kind of
research and figuring out how to ask
these questions and go through it in a
in a rigorous way and find satisfying
answers to difficult questions
um and it's something that I've been
able to do
you know working at a non-profit on the
triple as a non-profit um but there's a
lot of reasons why it's also good to
maintain contacts with academic
institutions so part of it is that
thinking of it from the association
perspective so many of our members work
on higher education either as professors
or graduate students and so it's good
for me to just be in touch with that
world on a professional level as well as
on a sort of member services or
conceptual you know reading about it
kind of level
um and so this gives me a kind of a
academic home base where I can have
professional colleagues that I can
support so for example I've I've done a
guest lecture in classes where people
are teaching things that intersects with
what I know
um to give you an example there's a
there's a
course that they're teaching now called
craft of anthropology where students
learn theory and method in a
project-based way
and so they're working with uh
a community near Washington DC they're
doing some
I think some archaeological work and
also oral histories
and for me coming into it with a
background in linguistics my question is
once you've taken that oral history
interview
what do you do with it yeah how do you
think about what people are saying to
you and interpret that and so I went in
and taught a sort of a mini workshop on
how to look at narrative
there's this idea that you know when you
do oral histories people tell you
stories
and there are ways of thinking about a
story as you know it has a beginning a
middle and an end
um and usually there when you get to the
end of it there's some like here's why I
told you that story
um and so you can look at it in a
structural way of what are the stages of
it but you can also look at it in a
functional way why are people telling
stories what kind of world are they
constructing so if I'm telling a
personal narrative it's a story about me
and I'm building this story world where
I'm a certain kind of a person dealing
with other kinds of people in a certain
way
and that is presenting a kind of like my
interpretation or representation of a
social reality
um and so for me looking at the
transcript as an analyst I can pull all
of these things out but there's another
level to it too whereby me telling you a
story
I in this real life world have decided
to tell you this story in this way for
some reason yeah and that tells me
something about who I am in the story
world but it also tells me something
about who I am in this world right now
of the storytelling World
um and what's going on in this interview
interaction uh how am I thinking about
participating in oral history how am I
how am I trying to represent you know my
Heritage to this researcher today
um and so uh what I was offering in that
setting was I have the analytic tools to
be able to look at these things
um and and talk it through
in a way that really complements
cultural anthropology and in exciting
ways yeah that's a really good way to
look at you know why is someone telling
a certain Story the way that they're
telling it about themselves oral history
and and I look forward to the work that
you end up doing as an anthropologist in
Residence and the continued work thank
you for the continued work at UH AAA
this is yeah this is an incredible place
and I feel very much like a kid in a
knowledge Haven right now thanks that's
crazy here yeah it's super fun Daniel
thank you for joining us on the show
yeah it's been a huge pleasure talking
to you it's been my pleasure thank you
and thanks everyone for tuning in we
greatly appreciate it give us your
thoughts in the comments below we'd love
to hear from you
um also go ahead and check out AAA the
links in the bio and much love everyone
Thanks for tuning in and go and build
the future manifest your destiny into
the world everyone peace